hell yeah i lost the cube and bigger
than this one i left it in the safe
forgot the code still got it safe
what's up gq today i'm gonna show you
guys some of the jewelry i already have
on plus
i'm gonna be buying jewelry because i
just got back from overseas wasting
money let's do it
[Music]
right here we have a star ring now i'm
saying straight from aviani
i'll be on the inside very heavy this is
30 000 right here on my pinky
i got another star ring on my index a
little smaller
you know anything vbs this is 10 right
here
i got the ap right here this will run
you about 60 70
for ap like this i got a big ass prong
setting
cuban link see those diamonds this is
aviani's prong setting this whole piece
together will run you like 125 130.
this all together right here these links
right here match my bracelet
the gucci links rose gold and white gold
with the vvs
this is about 15. how much is that total
i don't know about 120 right here uh
good 60 70 or honor somewhere in between
there
10 30 15.
i got the tennis under i don't know how
much it is a lot of money you guys can
put it up right here
add it up
now we're gonna do some shopping
[Music]
bring the jewelry in i'm johnny avigani
i brought some jewels for my boy smoke
perp today let's take a look
[Music]
you know i had to bring you the og piece
yeah
[Music]
i had this stored in the store this was
my first piece i bought from avioni
a little heart broken with the red
enamel inside
i have it tatted on my face like [ __ ]
love this wasn't really too much
like what like 15 18. yeah something
like that
starter piece now same purpose first
chain
[Music]
so this is a vs bracelet
one of one that's around 30 carats right
there
some light i brought you the new
prong bracelet cuban basically the old
style with the cubans they used to drill
the diamonds
into the cuban itself but now the new
style is the prong setting
damage outside yeah we had a sheet of
gold on top of every length
with prongs on it that holds the stones
in place this way you got more of a
shine and you don't lose gold weight
with the prong setting it sometimes
raises the price by about 25 to 50
percent
because the diamonds do get bigger when
you add the prongs and i like the prong
setting but bracelet wise i think i'm
taking this one today
this [ __ ] is just big and flooded this
is a lot of diamonds in one bracelet
like and it's big
so next i got a puff gucci link i know
you like the gucci legs it's a matchup
just like this same colors
this link is crazy the gucci link is one
of my favorites
and i never even really seen it like
this this one has
anchor pendant signifies holding weight
this piece will go for around 25
this chain is probably around 50. do the
math
custom stuff is fire they actually made
me a custom blessing
piece that's not done yet but sick i'll
come back and show you one
[Music]
this is an ankh in the egyptian culture
this signifies eternal life over here i
got
rose gold flooded out with a custom
popcorn link chain
basically what that means is every stone
is set separately
and it's almost like a martini setting
for the earrings except on the chain
as far as i'm around all around the lake
this chain got about 35
character stones in it and this pendant
you're working with about 15 carats
or vs forms a piece like this would take
about a week
while this chain will take around like
10 days to set it's a nice piece i
really like the pendant
personally i'm a like white gold type of
guy
but today i'm buying something rose gold
we got some praying hands over here with
a bunch down rope chain
i know a lot of you been wearing the
regular ones i don't think you've seen
the bust down one
so the rope chain is more of a classic
chain people used to wear it in the 80s
90s and still today is one of the most
popular chains that i see
we went ahead and did a little twist on
it added some diamonds too yeah i think
this is the first time i've seen a rope
chain with diamonds on it
over here you've got 50 carats in the
chain 23 carats in the pendant
this will run you back around 75 000
and now last but not least the piece i'm
here to buy
so over here we have very unique cuban
link one side with white diamonds
and the other side yellow diamonds and
over here we got a custom
jesus head one of one you can see the
size on that
so this is like 125 right here i was
expecting 100 but
i got you [ __ ]
solid you're the best for the best you
know what i mean exactly
and now i think i might want to get some
rings too
over here you got a custom pirate skull
ring this is dope i have two scorings so
i have two score rings already
i really had my eye on these two right
here this i call it the easter egg
because of the shape of course 16 and a
quarter carrots
or vs ones boom perfect size too
wow how much with this for me that one
right there is about 30 000.
25 you got it that wasn't even one you
thought you're gonna get
25 though
this this one right here is crazy this
right here is a part of the royal
collection
this is a very unique ring only limited
made
10 carats vs1 diamonds shining like a
star
i should probably start spending money
right now
i'm doing it for gq you take memo
[Music]
all right doing business i'll see you
soon i'm the first dude on gq to come in
here and buy jewelry
in gq and not only show my jewelers sky
step your game up bro
smoke perk aviani gq bow bow